hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 american science fiction
and action movie called beyond skyline
this movie is a sequel to the 2010 movie
skyline set concurrently with the events
of the first movie
the movie begins with a dying woman
named rose who was brought by several
men in an alien spaceship the scene
moves to los angeles where ex-detective
mark visits lapd to free his son trent
out of jail
there he meets up with officer garcia
mark's old friend who helps him out fed
up with his son's behavior he requests
garcia to lock trent up but he changes
his mind after garcia warns him that it
is final warning for his son
after that trend is released and it
seems like the relationship between them
is not too good for some reasons on
their way trent finally explains that he
got into trouble after he was insulted
by a man and he answered it with punches
which makes his father proud
suddenly the train crashes and loses its
power
mark with his detective instinct
approaches the train operator audrey who
claims that the radio somehow stops
working meanwhile outside the station
several blue lights start falling from
the sky
all passengers begin to panic as the
train crashes for the second time
audrey tries to calm them down and
suddenly someone on the radio warns them
not to look at the blue lights
the passengers rebel and decide to leave
the train on their own
mark leads them to escape through
underground tunnels they eventually
arrive at a subway station where trent
spots a blue light and follows it trent
and a woman who accidentally see the
blue light become helpless and walk
towards the light luckily mark arrives
on time and rescues his son
meanwhile garcia is confused when he
finds out everyone in the police station
is missing except his colleague jones he
brings a shotgun with him and checks the
situation outside with jones he is
shocked when he sees the entire
population is attracted by the light and
is sucked into an alien mothership
through the blue light
after trent regains his consciousness
mark audrey and the other survivors run
back into the underground tunnel where
they coincidentally meet garcia the
group decide to walk through the tunnel
and stay overnight there to avoid any
threats outside the next day mark
attempts to peek outside a tunnel and is
freaked out when he sees several combat
aircrafts approaching the alien
mothership but all of them are being
destroyed by the aliens
one of the missiles hits the mothership
and causes a huge explosion which causes
the underground tunnel to fall apart to
make things worse the remaining
survivors including sarge who is
sightless are confronted by an alien
mark grabs the shotgun and starts
shooting at it ruthlessly he seems to
manage to kill the alien and free garcia
from it but the alien suddenly awakens
and pulls jones's brain out of her head
they then learn that the alien needs a
brain to function and then starts
attacking them again the survivors try
to escape and mark manages to eliminate
the alien by exploding it meanwhile the
alien mothership is seen repairing
itself and begins to fly around again
they try to run out of the city but are
confronted by another alien garcia
volunteers himself to buy some time for
his friends but the alien is just too
strong for him and garcia gets sucked by
it mark audrey trent and sarge
eventually arrive at a port where
another huge alien appears and sucks all
of them into the alien mothership a few
moments later mark awakens finding
himself in a pile of unconscious humans
whose brains are ripped out of their
head by the alien and thrown out of the
vessel the arm is going to aim trent so
he shoots it to distract the arm which
draws the alien leader's attention and
he decides to suck everyone into another
chamber
mark almost gets caught by the arm but
he manages to escape and falls down
luckily for him his leg is stuck in one
of the ship's parts which prevents him
from free falling from the mother ship
at this point the alien leader is shown
trying to attack another part of earth
to collect more brains
mark climbs back to the mother ship and
discovers a lot of pregnant woman
corpses while continuing exploring the
vessel he is confronted by a blue-eyed
alien
mark is cornered but an alien with red
eyes suddenly shows up and helps him
ripping the brain out of its head
mark follows the kind-hearted alien and
comes across a woman elaine who is about
to give birth
turns out that the red-eyed alien was
previously jared the girl's former
boyfriend whose brain was implanted into
the alien machine or humanoid
jared somehow managed to control himself
and was not affected by the humanoid
after seeing his girlfriend was still
alive with mark's help elaine gives
birth to a little girl and unfortunately
passes away after the process
after that mark promises jared to get
his daughter off the ship since her
biological father has transformed into a
humanoid and jared decides to help him
to find his son
on their way the red-eyed alien equips
mark with an alien weapon by inserting
his arm into a hole
it is also revealed that jared plans to
blow the alien mothership
they eventually arrive at the control
room where the alien leader suddenly
appears
jared sends mark and his little girl to
another chamber where trant and audrey
managed to free themselves and attempt
to escape from the chamber they reunite
and come across sarge and try to help
him but an alien shows up and
unfortunately kills trent in the process
mark is enraged and fights the alien
thanks to his alien weapon he is now
able to kill the alien with his own
hands
on the other side the alien leader
battles jarrett and easily defeats him
he immediately heads over to the chamber
and attacks sarge who tries to protect
the baby from the alien the dying jared
uses his remaining power to destroy the
mothership which gives audrey and mark
more time to dodge the alien leader the
ship crashes in laos where the local
residents including sua and kanye are
trying to fight against the alien
invasion
mark audrey the baby and the wounded
sarge survive from the crash and escape
from the ship meanwhile the alien leader
also survives and begins the automatic
ship repair operation while preparing an
army to invade the nearby places
sarge dies on their way exploring the
land due to excessive loss of blood
they then meet kanye and sua who guide
them to a hut
kanye and suha find out that mark is a
cop thinking that he is in disguise
the fight between the americans and the
asians ensues
suddenly they spot the local police
officers patrolling who have been on the
warpath since the alien arrived they
then reconcile
sua kanya and the americans team up to
dodge the local police later that night
mark shares to the asians about the
alien machine or humanoids which
basically are still humans because they
need human brains to operate meaning
that all of them can be freed the next
morning mark awakens only to find out
that someone is pointing a gun at his
head
sue immediately takes him down
on the other side audrey is surprised
when she sees the little girl has grown
rapidly kanye and sue bring their new
allies to their hideout which is located
under a beautiful temple what shiva
turns out that the asians sell drugs for
their living no wonder if they hate cops
so much
there mark also meets scientist harper
who checks the girl's condition
afterward he examines the girl's blood
discovering that the girl might be an
alien because of her weird blood
structure aware of this kanye
immediately confronts the girl but mark
manages to calm her down saying that the
girl may be the key for them to free the
human mind inside the alien machine and
defeat the alien
after the situation subsides harper
explains that the girl will die due to
the rapid growth because it will deplete
her entire system since the girl needs
transfusion to survive mark volunteers
himself because one of his arms has been
affected by the alien weapon the scene
suddenly moves to rose the girl from the
beginning of the movie who finally
awakens and it seems like she remembers
something
back at the temple the transfusion works
well and the girl seems much healthier
than before
harper examines the blue egg which was
found by kanye earlier and discovers the
blue liquid stored within it which
allows the blue lights to control humans
mind
turns out that the blue liquid is
biologically compatible with human dna
indicating that the alien purposely
planted humans on earth and now comes
back to harvest
thanks to the little girl harper
believes that her serum can be their
ultimate weapon to free the human mind
inside the alien machine and then defeat
the alien
realizing that the aliens will come back
the humans prepare themselves and the
women plant some traps around the temple
suddenly an enormous alien appears and
starts chasing kanye she tries to lure
the alien to the minefield but
unfortunately she accidentally steps on
the landmine
left with no option she sacrifices
herself and the explosion kills both
kanye and the alien
however this allows the alien leader to
locate them and is ready to launch the
full attack on the temple
at this point harper has finished
developing the serum and mark who plans
to inject it to the aliens cannon takes
the syringe
the alien army arrives at the temple but
they don't realize that they have fallen
into humans trap
the explosion eliminates most of the
aliens but several aliens manage to
break into their hideout sua challenges
an alien to a duel and manages to burn
it to death
meanwhile mark sneaks into the alien
mothership while the humans prepare for
the upcoming battle however mark is
spotted by one of the aliens and gets
attacked
turns out that the alien was inserted
with trent's brain and mark realizes
that a few moments later mark manages to
inject the serum into one of the bullets
which allows alien trent to remember his
memories and regain consciousness
outside the mothership the enormous
alien machine which is controlled by the
alien leader appears and wreaks havoc at
the temple
harper is killed when he tries to save
audrey from the emerging alien
the alien leader spots the red bullet
and destroys the launcher which prevents
it from being launched
afterward the humans reunite and
continue to battle the aliens but this
time they managed to outpower them and
slaughter the emerging aliens not long
after the huge alien leader approaches
them but suddenly is attacked by alien
trend the battle continues when the
little girl silently walks towards the
launcher and somehow manages to fix it
the alien trent grabs the launcher and
shoots the red bullet which kills the
alien leader the bullet emits a very
bright red light which allows the aliens
to control themselves and regain their
human consciousness
after the historical battle against the
alien audrey decides to name the little
girl rose turns out that the woman at
the beginning of the movie was the
little girl and now rose is ready to
fight back and destroy the entire alien
race
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching